[Music]
all right so good morning everyone thank
you so much for joining to this webinar
before we get started I would like to
review what you can expect out of
today's presentation first is that we
have new sites administration so if you
have followed
Sparky on for some time hopefully
today's material will be new to you also
the demo code that we're gonna use today
I'm calling and reproducible many to say
that we're not going to use a large
spark data cluster or are your own
cluster that tastes all this stuff I
mean nobody can ever recreate that I'm
gonna use local mode maybe because I
want to focus on what Sparky does and
because how cool it is that you can also
do local mode and actually one spark
I'll be able to show you some of the
inner workings of spark as well as we go
through the code even though this is not
a what's new in Sparky yard today this
webinar I will be highlighting some of
the new features in Sparky are there's
three specific features that I'm very
excited about to share with you today so
we'll be definitely reviewing those
since switching here the goal today is
to share with you something new and
useful so if you have been you see
sparkly or for a while that one or two
things that you can pick up today that
you can try later or at home or
something that that would be they'll be
great or if you're new to Sparky are
that hopefully most of this presentation
will be beneficial for you alright so
let's move to the first slide so I was
actually trying to look for something
that would represent this overall
architecture and ended up just putting
this together usually we talk about you
know sparkly R & R how Sparky era
provides a deep layer back
and to spark how it also makes machine
learning libraries available there
inside spark in our and that of course
you can create extensions but behind all
that I'm going to take a few minutes to
review how rude everything starts from
the storage and ends up in our with this
method so for example we have big data
storage sources like for example HDFS or
Hadoop we can have an s3 bucket
databases file systems that all are
access in spark be a package now these
packages are not to be confused with our
packages these are spark packages that
are specific to the kernel data source
that you can access right so let's say
that you want to access that a redshift
database via spark then you would use a
specific package to be able to do that
and so that spark can read the data so
one spark is connected to your big data
source then it opens the door for all
these really cool things like cluster
computing the fact that you can do all
this stuff in memory it's really big
also the fact that you can extend the
API meaning that not only has things
that come out of the box like the
machine learning libraries but also you
can create your own programs that can
run in parallel another thing is that it
provides a Seco interface when you're
interacting with data which is really
good because it allows a very easy way
to to start using your data with spark
and also enables something like the
things like the deep layer back-end for
example one of the most important things
I want to mention here as a tip or
something that sometimes is not fully
clear is that spark is not in itself
data storage all the data comes from the
it's the source which sometimes causes
some confusion because you may have a
different product data product that says
hey we can access all these data sources
like Oracle we can ask
Paulo we can Essex Park right so spark
looks like a data source but it's really
not that's because the product interacts
with spark which in turn interacts with
something in the background but spark
doesn't have data when as soon as you
turn off the session the data that you
would have cache in memory is gone right
so that's very important to notice
because that will help as you are
working with Sparky our how to manage
those data frames and the data that
you're interacting with so we mentioned
that spark access the big data sources
we're packages and then spark VR uses
the spark shell to to access the spark
capabilities and then it makes it
available to are all these cool things
we have functions are functions so let's
go ahead and dig deeper into this
portion right here about the spark shell
and Sparky are I wanted to kind of
illustrate how sparkly are not only
opens the door for us to be able to use
I wanna say us I mean our users to be
able to interact with sparkly API but
inside our by providing a conduit where
you can think literally send API calls
right you could have stopped right there
and I would have been extremely excited
if sparkly I would have done just that
and so I can send Seco commands via an
API call but they didn't stop there the
guys that worked in this package also
created record functions that makes it
very easy for us to access it like
functions we can call machine learning
algorithms but simply call an ml
underscore function or an SD F function
which stands for a spark data frame or a
feature transformer or a spark
underscore functions all these are very
easy to use because make sense in the
art world but in the backend is doing
all these API calls in spark that we
don't have to worry about also provides
a deep layer backhand that I mentioned
which we are going to dig in deeper in a
little bit so I'm going to table this
one for for now I move to the invoke
command
so the in Bochum and it is the one that
enables us to do those API calls
directly if we were editor reason
there's not a function in sparkly yard
that does what we need with spark then
we can use them both comment to do it
now the real purpose of the invoke
command is to actually enable other
packages to become extension so sparkly
are so that other companies or people
can create their own things via sparkly
R and R to interact to spark like for
example h2o has a package that allows us
to run h2o algorithms inside spark
through our via that extension package
so it's really cool I think the approach
that have year and Kevin and JJ took
when they created this package because
it really enables and empowers us to be
able to do a lot of things with spark
and not only the one thing you know not
only deep liar not only the sequel not
only machine learning it does open the
door for almost everything that we had
there dig in deeper into the deep layer
backend
I think it's important to mention that
if you already are using the tidy verse
then switching over to Sparky R is
actually not too sparkly are about to
spark it's gonna be a natural thing to
do especially as we see that code today
you can use the same mutate filter
summarized functions it with spark data
friend data and instead of you know the
those words to run in memory you know we
did a memory it's actually running
remotely and doing that made data
manipulation inside the spark cluster
the secret sauce to all this is the fact
that sparkly are actually translate
those deep layer verbs in an vector
expressions and vectors
into actual sequel statements so an
example that you can see here is for
example that using the TDL command and
then a simple select verb gets
translated into a sequel a sequel
command that get then gets sent back to
spark now having said that let me go
back to that initial slide that I showed
you and I think it's really nice to
mention the fact that the deep layer
backhand will do that where we mentioned
does the the Seco transition that Seco
statement gets sent to spark and then
spark depending on the data sources in
the backend like I mentioned you could
be redshift it could be s3 the file
system it then does the appropriate data
you know transformation or data
selection to get the data back right so
we we can send the same select command
and flights to be ten different types of
data sources and it will always work
right so it is abstracting that
complexity for us which i think is
really awesome because it allows us to
interact with a bunch of different data
sources and keep a consistent interface
having said that the fact that it goes
all the way back to the data source and
then into spark that's one way that we
can access the data which depending on
the data storage itself it may be slow
or fast we actually have more than one
option to do this the first one is the
one I already mentioned the fact that
you can go back all the way to the data
source and get the data into our but the
second option that spark has that is
really powerful is the fact that you can
also cache data in spark right so we can
tell spark to go ahead and take a piece
of the data it doesn't reside some data
in the data source and keep it in memory
so that way whenever we start
interacting with the data we don't have
to go all the way back into a possible
slow system and get to bring the data in
we can just interact with the data in
here
obviously the idea that we don't want to
start just using this as a sort of ETL
tool you don't want to bringing all the
data into our we want to take advantage
of deep liar to manipulate as much of
the data and aggregated before we bring
the results back again as I mentioned
there's no story to spark so just
remains true which when what happens is
when you cache the data into spark as
soon as we killed a spark session that
cache data's going to go away so it's
great while you analyze him but it's not
going to be something that you can use
for for a lack of better term a
persistent storage so for the demo today
we're going to review some of the
sparkly are functions that and we're
going to basically do a high-level and
kind of hit as many as we can as many
functions as we can as far as types of
functions also we're gonna switch over
to the spark UI doing the analysis at
certain points of the analysis so you
can see what's there in the background
we also talked about reading and caching
data and spark I mentioned that in a
highlight some of the new features in
Sparky are and this we're gonna share
with you some of the tips and tricks
okay so let me switch over to the code
and I started all the way from
installing the new packages right so
this code you can literally run it on
your laptop and it should work so I'm
going to start by loading the libraries
and then I'm going to run this one even
they already have it installed so it's
not no problem make sure that you run it
at two one zero SPARC version the first
time you run this gonna take a little
bit but it's gonna be worth it so this
is what I want to actually start
formally so the first thing I want to
mention is that you can start the spark
connect with no configuration but in
this case I do want to modify the
configuration I want to request sixteen
gigabytes of driver memory and I'm going
to request that 80% of those 16
gigabytes are you
for me to use in my analysis the default
of this is 40% so I don't pass this it's
going to give me even less than that so
I'm gonna run this and I'm gonna connect
so once it's connected you'll notice
that my tab may be called a little bit
different if you are in version 1 it
says spark
mine says connections that's because I'm
using the preview release of the IDE so
that's been renamed to connections
because it's being expanded you also
include other kinds of database
connections which is another cool thing
to mention but still I may be subject
for a different webinar so here we can
see that we don't have tables yet and
that's because I'm just I just open a
local connection to spark that actually
opens in studio that actually creates a
new session for me that I can go to the
web UI so this is the web UI for my
current spark application and I went
directly normally kiss comes in here
jobs without having any jobs yet I'm
going to execute her to show you the
fact that it gave me the 12 gigabytes
right which is 80% of 16 gigabytes so I
have a 12% at 12 gigabyte sorry a
portion from a spark session and 8 cores
so that's gonna give me all this
capabilities obviously if I had a
cluster it would be more more exact
heaters here available to me but in this
case we're gonna have one because it's
my local machine next thing I want to do
someone will load some data I have a
script here that will allow you to copy
the data into the right folder if you
don't have it yet so again I want to
keep it as for producible as possible I
have this little routine that will get
the column names from those files we're
using two files for flights
that a full year of each of of the years
mentioned here is their safety mat data
folder so when I run this command right
here the spark read what it's doing it's
creating a new flight stable in the
spark environment and also is pointing
spark to that data folder as the data
source
I'm filling in not to cash it in memory
and to use the file columns variable
that I loaded here and not to try to
figure out the schema this actually
saves me a lot of time because usually
if I don't pass at these two then the
command will run a lot slower and
switching over here to storage you'll
notice that I don't have anything yet
right that's because all I'm doing is
I'm telling spark where the files are
even though I've only done that you
notice that that variable that I'm
equating to the spark read I found run
this is only given the size of it is
only you know nine nine thousand nine
hundred thirty six bytes so it's
obviously not all the data that's
because it's just a pointer to that to
that database to that table actually I'm
leaving a table right is the data but I
can actually access it directly here if
I were to click this button the table
button is going to into these files and
treated them as if they were a data
source right and it's giving me a
preview of my data right out of my out
of my interface here another thing I can
do is of course I can start interacting
with my data using sequel so I'll run
this command right here and I'm gonna
use the library
DBI package and I'm gonna use the get
query function from DVI to pull the top
one soon about ten records
I made this available because I want
highlight the fact that whenever you run
DB cat query you actually bring him back
the data into our memory so it does
create a data frame right this is
important to mention because if you're
gonna use DB get query and you don't do
limits or aggregations or something it's
gonna try to bring back all of your data
so just gonna watch out for that yeah
you may end up with a sequel statement
that's either gonna crash your session
because it's trying to bring much of too
much data it's gonna take forever to run
another cool thing is that we can run
sequel statements inside an R chunk so
you notice how usually we have are the
beginning of a coaching and our markdown
if you rename that to sequel and then
point the connection to that variable
the SC variable then I can actually run
it directly here very useful whenever
I'm trying to use like the double quote
here that I don't have to I would have
to do more things to make it work if I'm
gonna use double quote so that that's
one of the times I seem like it makes it
much easier especially if I'm copying
and pasting a sequel statement from
somewhere else just works directly in
the code chunk I said that's a decimal
way that we can interact with sequel as
excuse me with sparklies using sequel
and you'll notice to you and I think the
biggest point that I forgot to mention
is the fact that we are using sequel
statements to interact with data that is
not a simple you know base databases
file system so that's another cool thing
that you are able to do now with spark
just like we mentioned right we send in
Sparks equal and spark is taking care of
the data retrieval for us we can also
use the plier so me don't have so much
these code chunks in fact let me go
ahead and throw my output that way I
don't have to keep on turning them off
all right do so with Eclair
the same espy flights variable that we
used to load to read the data in again
I'm using intake and select use an
example of how we can interact with the
data so instead of having to write the
sequel ourselves we can use the plier to
start selecting data and do some data
conversions here same thing right
the flights table is only a pointer and
it's not bringing the data back if I
were to run this actually let me let me
move to this next one the next thing I
want to show you is show query so I had
SP flights which is pointed to the
flights table and I'm going to tell to
just give me the the top rows I can run
this and notice that because I have show
query at the end of this batch code
segment it's actually we're giving me
the sequel statement that I'm using this
is a very handy tool just to figure out
especially if you having errors why is
not running like you wanted to why does
it give me an error but another way that
we found it becomes very useful
especially from feedback that we've
gotten from commercial customers starts
to it has is the fact that you can have
more complex deep liar code right here
and then translate it into into sequel
that then can be shared with other team
members inside your inside the company
or the team itself that may take that
sequel statement and run it in a
different tool right so not only gives
you the ability to transform data easily
but also gives you the ability to take
that you know sequel statement and share
that same you know analysis with others
via that sequel command so that's that's
something that we found out and in a
sense you know so show query is another
thing that we can use all right so let's
talk about caching data and spark so I'm
gonna run this as I'm talking here and
whereas doing is doing a simple tally
which is of course is to count asteroids
as is doing that and
switch over again to the interface here
and you notice that the job is still
running so it's gonna take a while and
as it's running I think it's important
to mention too that if you're new to
spark you can it's important to note
that every time you run something it's
going to create a job right so right
here finished it and you were looking
the background and ran here so it took
22 seconds to count 13 million six
hundred seventeen thousand records so
that's a significant amount of time and
what it's doing is worth just going to
the these files and doing a full file
read and getting all the girls and women
back so that takes a long time you know
19 seconds so in order for us to be able
to get this performance up we're gonna
have to bring that data into spark
memory and we do that using the compute
command which is one of the this is the
first command that it's new just
Berkeley are we can say that's I'm very
very excited about because usually you
will have to do s DF register and then
TBL cash to get the data into memory but
now compute that's both for us and what
this is going to do as I'm running it
because you'll see that creates a new
job right so everything we do in SPARC
is going to be a job so it's going to
take a little bit here and then it's
running want to get to one of nine so I
can switch over to storage and this is
very common to as you start working a
lot with SPARC looking and clicking jobs
they go back to storage see how it says
like subset which is the name we gave it
here in the compute is 30% cached so
NASA 100% cached so now it took there
the resulting the results of that the
desire the desire code
and catch them in memory so now it's
cash in at 358 megabytes and it's split
in eight partitions these eight
partitions each one of them is around
forty five megabytes so it is pretty big
but still now it's in our RAM right and
it's taking some of that twelve
gigabytes that we requested from the for
the driver so now that this is computed
I'm going to run the same Kali command
will you notice that it was immediate
right yes and if we switch back here
you know everything creates a job it was
less than a second right half a second
to run so you can see even a local mode
how you know how much performance you
can get out of cashing your data and how
important that is for data analysts
right because then now this allows you
to iterate constantly over the data
without the text of having to go back
every time to get more information or
wait for it to read the times if the
files again that would allows us to do
more I'm calling a complex aggregations
obviously this is not complex but if it
took 19 seconds just to do a straight
count can you imagine how long it's
going to take to split it by the origin
this would be the airport origin and
then give me the count and take forever
so I wouldn't venture myself to do that
without having my data cached another
cool thing that we can see in Sparky our
serpent 6 that I want to highlight is an
improved way of doing sampling so if you
use sample frac or sample in and deep
liar you can use the same one and
sparkly R and if you tried it before 0.6
it was probably really really slow for
you just know that that's improved now
that's gonna be much faster than before
and it's going to get a bit while here
but it is much much better than it was
because it's using a more native way of
sensing to spark than to do a more
complex operations like it was doing
before another tip I want to mention is
the fact that between sample frac and
sample n inside spark is dressed the
same table sample to man but for some
recent table sample with just a number
like a sample n doesn't work as well in
my opinion a sample frac the result here
you notice that between the two years
that we have in the data it's pretty
even bringing in the data from both
files when I try this and example n it
actually just brings more data from 2003
I tested this some time back again and
it was the same thing so our
recommendation is that you use sample
frac and you serve fraction of the data
just submit again this is known as but
we are things more of a spark you know
how or even the eyes with selection how
it works
new and deep layer so if you attended
Hadley's latest webinar talking about
what's latest was new and deep layer
serpent 7 we've had pool in case when I
wanted to bring out that pool in case
wind does work in spark here and I think
really really nice especially pool I use
it all the time it lets you take the
first column if I don't pass anything or
if I pass a the name of a field then
it's gonna take that field and bring it
back as a vector of course this is
character vector that I can then do so
there's things very convenient because
we always end up having to do some sub
setting after running a command will
never use full unity collect so it makes
it very convenient right at the end of
our chunk here and and right now we're
using it for actual analysis right so we
tell them that to give me the top five
airports with the most activity right so
we cap the top five here ordered by how
much activity they have case when
works and I did a quick one here as far
as if its origin it's a phantom is the
biggest and then do use numbers
depending on how many flights it has and
everybody else do a default variable so
it is over 200 taciturn Jake over
100,000 is medium and everybody else is
small and then you can see that working
and you saw how fast that is I'm not
running this in in our memory right
everything is brand in spark and it runs
really fast because how optimized it is
here and the fact that is broken out
into smaller files we thought we I
mentioned SDF functions this is the
second function I want to highlight
because I think's really awesome how it
works and we've had a lot of customers
and folks that just we are using Sparky
are asking about you know what about
spread you know Teddy are always you
spread and I have to bring the data into
memory and then do spread there so now
with SDF people you can do basically the
same operation and for those of you that
I haven't done have a new spread yet I
want to show you basically the concept
of it so here if I were to have group by
the data input by origin and destination
I'm taking my top five airports and then
I want each instead of having each
combination like this but rather I want
to see just one line for DFW one line
for the one line for a H and then a
column for each of the destinations and
the number inside those columns right if
I want that crosstab you know look to it
you can actually do all that inside
spark but just sending that to SDF pivot
to run this and the pivoting itself is
taking place in a spark so I'll
for those of you whose be wanting this
function for a while to you know catch
your breath a little bit
alright so feature transformers I
actually didn't use feature transformers
as much but then I found out that
there's more to meet the I hopefully you
got that reference so the first one I
want to show you is the feature by
analyzer
that one will lets us do something
really cool which is if a numeric column
has is over a certain value then it's
gonna assign a value of one
and if none is going to be a zero right
so in this case is working with lights
let's say that we want to tag anything
that is consider at the date flight
which is anything that's over 15 minutes
so if I run this you'll notice that I
still to look at the departure delay and
it is over 15 minutes then create a new
column called delayed and make it one if
it's over 15 minutes right so you don't
have to use if else you don't have to
use more complex logic to make it work
in sequel or and declare you can just go
feature binarize err and you get that
functionality all these feature your
transformers are meant for you know data
preparation for analysis right so we'll
see that in a minute how we can actually
combine all these future bucket Iser
is another really cool one this one will
allows us to do basically the same as
cut so I can send it the splits and it
takes and sample here the departure hour
give me the scheduled departure and then
depending on the time range it'll give
me a number right so if it's 0 to 400
stemi 0 400 to 800 MB 1 800 to 1200 s 2
and so forth right so this will lets us
create you know dos more you know
segments inside our data
then we can use for other things that of
course running as a model another way
that I found that's very useful is if
you want to create a histogram with it
that it's it's much faster to run a
future bucket i sir
then try to do this with a sequel
statement to create the buckets because
obviously it's using a lower level API
inside spark alright so going to a
machine learning libraries here before
we go into that I want to show you here
how we can combine deep layer burps with
feature transformers with SDF functions
and get them to all work together to to
run an analysis so the new feature a new
unit function here is that SDF partition
so I can get it where I can tell spark
to run the training I create a subset
for training at one percent of the data
a subset for testing and nine percent of
the data and then hold everything else
for 90 percent so as the a partition
requires you that the total of this
needs to be one so just knowing how I do
it because I don't want to split it you
know 40 50 because it is debate in this
case so I want to use just one percent
to run a demo training today
usually you would be able to do like
type it and then compute here but what
happens here is that sample smusd a
partition actually creates one spark
data frame for each of the splits so you
have to specify which one you want to we
want to cash right so in this case our
cash training and it's important for me
to mention here Sarge now we have
training right it's a much much smaller
as set at five megabytes and it's also
partitioned in eight partitions this is
I want to mention
because we're gonna come back to this
because of our different function that I
want to show you all right so I'm going
to train the model here I'm going to use
logistic regression
so the laid is the same one that we used
earlier using the feature better nicer
so cr1 just a later not the party relays
continuous variable and then departure
hour which is that one that we use a
feature bucket i sir but in this case i
did this i use the paste that to to add
an H to the hours to make sure that it
uses it's recognized as a categorical
variable instead of a instead of a
continuous variable
I'm sure there's better ways to do this
so I apologize if I didn't do it the
best way but this worked pretty well for
me so again I want to just kind of give
you a sample of what it you know model
would look like
I ran the an SDF predict so that's the
name implies it would run in the
predictions but instead of running in
over the training data running over
testing data I didn't catch this data
because you saw that it runs really
quickly so it's ok I real depends on how
big your data is I want to show you the
top records because there's some
differences from how a predictable seer
was the Esper did specifically and the
difference is that it will return the
same data set that you send it sent to
it but with more fields and you'll
notice that immediately we can see that
the departure hour has been actually
sparkly R has created dummy variables
for us for each of the values inside
departure hour and it returns a
prediction right so we have a prediction
of serial one and the actual value of
zero one so now we can see how the model
performed here so I'm going to do
was gonna compare it and see we do it
there's obviously much better ways than
doing that this you know in but I guess
I want to highlight the fact that you
are able to run those models inside
spark without bringing your data back
into memory to just the results in this
case right so we can see our our false
positives or two negatives you can see
which ones where false positives and
true positives so they're okay and now
we can iterate through the data of
course we have cache the training data
so if you want to test different models
it's not going to take forever to run
all right so our last feature I want to
feature to talk about today is
distributed our we've had several people
and customers asking for this the the
capability of being able to take an hour
function and run it in spark right this
is a big big new thing that a sparkly
our hats in this next version so because
it's brand new
I've definitely suggest that before you
start writing up solutions using it that
you test it real well in your cluster
before you you implemented we're
constantly working on improving it so I
think in itself already a sports shown
it to you today and so you can see how
it works
so I'm going to run a spark apply which
is the command that we will use to be
able to distribute our data
let's give me our functions in spark and
I'm just going to use a very simple word
coat and row right so the Android
command we would expect to return one
number but actually we turn eight and
what that means is what it's doing is
taking this account from each of these
rdd's in spark and giving us a count
right so inside this 700 kilobytes
memory chunk it's around 18,000 records
right so this is ok you know because we
can run it over each of these data
frames but normally we don't want it we
don't want the data group
there are DDS we want some sort of
custom grouping so the team has created
this group by argument that you can use
to run that you know parallel you know
deployment of QR code right because
that's usually what you wanted why do
you want to use our code in part because
you wanted to run parallel right you
want to run the same machine learning
algorithm over specific categories the
same you know whatever function that was
those categories so you want to use
that's that's the reason why right so
then you have this and now now I can
group it by the departure hour and the
last one and I'm running out of time is
the fact that you can run something like
like a broom function and run
essentially the same y LM function over
each of the origin airports and it will
return a tidy data set but all this did
not run at any point inside my from our
code so very excited about this I think
it's really cool I hope you get you
start testing it and give us some
feedback because this will open a lot
more doors or how you can you spark and
sparkly are hopefully this will be one
of the tools and your tool set and
unsteady to set you saw how we can
effectively use the other pieces and
other functions that make this
combination with tools really exciting
okay so I think I'm this is the end of
the demo let me go back to so thank you
so much Xavier and I believe Jim Hester
were answering questions so they marked
some here for me it says the first one
says assessment the line read CSV is run
the data loaded in memory or not where
does this data reside good question so
if you say weird yes here
so let me go to help out here so you
notice that you have a memory true right
so if you say true then it's going to go
to that storage section in it in here
but if you set that to false then what
it's doing in the background it's
actually creating a sort of mapping that
there's just like a temporary mapping of
how the files are put together
essentially it's this still partitioned
but virtually we can say if I had time I
could show you more about it because you
can actually go into the scratch folder
inside SPARC and see the files that it
creates that that are the mapping files
so that's that's how that works
any suggestions on where we do cache
lodal data into spark memory what if the
memory is not big enough to store all
the data yeah so that's that's a very
good question
so I think it depends on what you're
doing at that point so if you do in it
EDA for example then one of two things
would be possible especially if you're
limited on the amount of memory one
would be to only bring in columns that
are of interest right so there may be
some you know jump columns that we don't
want to we don't really care about think
for example here I can show you like
like these columns all these n icons I
would never bring in and right so I
would subset it and then try to see if
that subset of columns would fit and if
not then you can always do sampling
right and as I showed you
sampling within sample frac works pretty
good as far as getting a good sampling
over all the data out there helper
scripts available for installing
uncommon free structure such as AWS EMR
knows that is a very good question I'm
actually gonna have another webinar
about deploying sparkly R and spark then
I will Google cover that at that point
in time let's see I think I saw one
about plotting okay I am very passionate
about associations with big data so I
will mention real quick that obviously
for plotting you cannot plot in spark
right now so you have to bring the data
back into into R for plotting so as I
mentioned earlier one of the techniques
that I use for like histograms is to
bring the data back using assuming
calculated buckets in spark and then
bring the results and create a histogram
for example or you can do two bucket
icers right to create some sort of
raster plot so yeah this definitely ways
that you can take advantage of spark
spark step abilities but you would have
to do the calculation sort of plot
inside memory and then bring the results
back
it's daunting at first but once you get
used to it it's actually really easy to
replicate so I would definitely
encourage you to take a look at that oh
there's more questions coming in okay
cool so how do we know how much memory
it's using what if the memory out flows
good questions so if for you to know how
much memory is being consumed obviously
your limit is in this case twelve
gigabytes but if you go back to its de
heaters Jimmy O to see how much is being
used out of those twelve gigabytes at
any point in time then that will tell
you right there and also you can see it
here it says Sparky RT very slow
compared to the PI spark yeah I would
like to know that what kind of methods
you using with Spartacus as I mentioned
Sparky ours approach to accessing the
spark well yet yeah
accessing the the cluster is just
through spark shell so there's nothing
else that we do other than call this
part shell commands so not sure if yeah
and I think have your two sensor to open
up issue yeah all right and keep all
this code
and the presentation will be available
as I mentioned in our github is gonna be
our studio 4/2 webinars
[Music]